hello and welcome to this video playing
international master my astro ASX okay
i'm just playing a very classic on set
up okay five that's very early okay I'm
going for check I'm going for the
endgame here let's see what to do here
may be cancelled check normally those
endgames don't promise much but wasn't
so sure here I mean have don't have a
pawn on c4 and so on that looks looks
like one of the better versions of half
of this end game should be Julie wants
to go v6 that gives me some options the
night may be coming to defile so I don't
mind to provoke that I just have to be a
bit circumspect with my pawn down on
your form I definitely like to keep it
safely protected like this he might have
bishop age 6 well again it's tough to
tough to prevent Bishop takes b6 by the
way could be a threat in this position
almost
ok
yeah he's playing something that you
might call goalkeeper chest it just it
keeps everything kind of yeah kind of
two so that he just holds it in some
some kind of way see isn't b5
technically interesting check check
check can you [ __ ] that night or
something I don't know I'm not even a
porn up here this is Sir sir this is
what Chang but now I'm going to be a
pawn up yeah the weird thing is that it
might not be might not be an advantage
amazing yeah avoid the book trade here
somehow and they're probably not
remarkable he's got King c5 coming and
this is it wrong and came to itself
enjoy there are often probably
continuous you up like King III I make
my usual mistake this is a kind of this
is not really nothing happens it's just
totally dead but I'm playing yeah
because I'm just not paying any
attention anymore
and this is this is all from costing me
games could have taken you for already
know okay it was a complete draw before
I just have to go King III
draw ever John this is a waste of time
check check so important where to go
probably yeah a little bit
ok amazing that he just could escape to
that end game in the first place but
just seems to be what it is
yeah nothing to do him check check check
game drawn yeah now I could have come
gotten in trouble and then game I just i
blundered the pawn at one mode yeah okay
yeah i thought that should be better for
white that thing it is better somehow
but couldn't really get much so here and
I find it amazing how we just dashed out
everything so quickly there okay night
DC form is that more precise I mean okay
it's always a little bit because this is
not an ideal porn formation okay I think
it wasn't so bad yeah maybe b5 is
ultimately not leading to that much we
get check their exactly the the game and
just just have it it's just a drawing
check yeah of course just King III yeah
this is the thing I'm I just I just I'm
a bit disappointed that I didn't get him
got more out of it and then I'm kind of
shutting down my thinking I'm just not
thinking anymore i'm just playing or
whatever it's the draw and I should just
play King III and it's easy and after
this it's not so easy I mean it's still
at all but it's completely unnecessary
to to go down or no I'm now taking
bishop b6 it's a very clear thing and
I'm just dashing I would some move sir
FF txt is ridiculous you can do
he's winning after that if i go here
it's still a complete wrong they
actually recognized during the game that
I'm that I'm drifting here you can win
again with bishop jakes you for does
this notice win check check because now
I don't have a passer but he does yeah
it's a drawing chan chan remarkable yeah
I do that all through that time it
turned again and or that weakness but
still it happens especially in blitz
games it happens that moment where I
feel okay the game is essentially over
and sometimes I even offered wrong and
went from pure position point of view on
justified and then they decline and I'm
completely not not paying any attention
and I mean this is not like I'm too
stupid to recognize what I need to do
here it's just that I don't look I
simply don't pay any attention and King
you three would mean this is the easiest
draw ever even with two minutes down on
the clock because he played it so
quickly very lucky that I didn't lose
this okay thanks for watching